Hey everybody, Dr. Cotters again. I'm gonna talk to you about the foot-backed apparatus that is an add-on to the Atelier Robin P-220, right machine.
It's a lot different than maybe you've seen before. It's actually really heavy too.
Very meaty, so it puts out a lot of surface area for that energy to go across, which makes this, you know, super superior.
You'll notice that it's got a red and a black side.
All right, the core that comes with this is kind of red and a black side, too.
They're just alligator clips that you're gonna clip on this to rub this foot-backed apparatus.
Pretty simple, you'll clip it on there, and then you're gonna put this in the water in your foot-back.
So this is a foot-back that comes with it. You could use any tub that you could put your feet in, and you're gonna put more water in there.
So it's not cold on your little tutsis, and you're gonna put a heaping tablespoon of salt.
Now, the amount of salt that you use is really gonna depend upon the water in your area.
So you're gonna have to experiment with that a little bit.
So the nice thing about this is it puts out a lot of energy into that.
It's gonna pull a lot of junk out, and you're gonna be shocked when you see what this foot-back is gonna look like after you do a program.
The negative is that you'll go through these plates after about 40, 50, 60 sessions.
So this comes with an extra plate that you'll replace.
Pretty easy to unscrew this and put your new plates on.
It's a lot less expensive than buying a whole new apparatus.
These are just $20 for these plates, or I think they're 15 if you buy them in bulk.
And then you'll change the plate, and you'll be able to go for another 50 sessions or so.
Now, this connects to the machine.
Obviously, you need the frequencies.
So, obviously, the alligator clips are connected to the foot-back apparatus, and then this is connected to the P220 machine in the auxiliary port.
Just like that.
Then you'll switch this to auxiliary, you can leave this plugged in if you want.
That's the bulb. You'll switch it to auxiliary, and you'll run a program that you want to run through this.
It'll come out the foot-back in the water, put your feet in the water, with the salt, and you're gonna run that for the length of the program,
or whatever you want to hit stop of the program, clean your bucket, clean your apparatus, and you're ready to go for next session.
Just remember, if you're gonna go back to bulb, switch it back to bulb.
And take out your auxiliary port.
Keep your things clean. It'll last 40, 50, 60 sessions, and easy to change when you want a new one.
You don't have to buy a whole new apparatus. You just buy the plates.
They're great little units. You're gonna love this.